just a few brief comments before
introducing John cotesworth Provost who
introduced Nick this is an occasion of
course in which we really celebrate the
commitment of the university to ideas
and and scholarship and all the things
that we we value so so much here so it's
the University lecture is really that
it's also a wonderful occasion to have
Nick Dirk's give the talk he's going to
give because he is steeped in this world
of area studies of course of
anthropology his his field and the whole
area of how has this study of regions of
the world developed the third reason is
because we're now living in this very
world in a way that is highly connected
to these earlier episodes the one in
particular that he's going to talk about
in the pre-world War to World War 2 era
and we're all trying to figure out in
universities
what does globalization mean and after
we've thought about that what does it
mean for our great universities and many
institutions are giving different
answers to that and some are setting up
branch campuses and Abu Dhabi and Qatar
and Singapore and so on and this
institution has a different philosophy
but it's it's one among several that are
being debated and should be debated and
so this is a university lecturer that is
very closely tied to the questions we're
facing as an institution both higher
education and in Colombia today so we're
very grateful to Nick for taking this up
and now I give you John Coates worth
Thank You president volunter and good
evening to you all it is fair to say
that across Columbia's campuses Nick
Dirk's
is most closely identified with his
duties as executive vice president for
the Arts and Sciences and Dean of the
faculty he has served in these roles for
eight years he is responsible for five
different Columbia schools twenty-nine
departments and 27 institutes and
centers during an academic era defined
in part by the rise of interdisciplinary
learning Nick has been a leader in
forging closer ties between and among
Columbia's many academic disciplines in
his own words he is focused on quote the
interdependency of knowledge and yet if
that job description leaves you a bit
breathless it fails to touch upon an
essential part of Nick's contribution to
Columbia's academic community his own
powerful and widely admired body of
scholarship Nick came to Columbia to
lead and rebuild the university's
illustrious Department of Anthropology
he is today the franz boas professor of
anthropology in history a chair named
after a giant in the field whom you will
hear more about in a moment professor
Dirk's interests encompass the history
of enter and anthropology of South Asia
British colonialism the history of
imperialism and cultural theory his
research and extensive writing has
changed our understanding of how British
rule shaped the indian subcontinent and
how in turn the colonies influenced
britain's development reviews have
called his books quote lucid and
masterful and quote brilliant works of
historical excavation and have praised
him for quote vaporizing comforting
visions of Britain's Empire may be most
impressive of all of all the students of
Columbia College who as we know can be
our most demanding critics awarded
professor Burt dirt
with the 2002 Lionel trilling award for
his book casts of mind colonialism and
the making of modern India Nik Dirk's
has been at Guggenheim Fellow a
MacArthur Fellow a Fulbright fellow and
is a member of the Council on Foreign
Relations president Bollinger just
described his the scholarship on display
at these lectures as remarkable and
inspiring and those adjectives certainly
apply to Nik Dirk's handling of his
subject tonight it is worth noting that
the trajectory of area studies in the
United States during and after World War
Two was traumatic in 1940 only 60
doctoral students in US universities
were awarded PhDs for the study of the
contemporary non-western world a quarter
century later in 1965 there were 65,000
graduate students including me enrolled
in programs focused on these areas in US
universities to some observers including
many perhaps most congressmen area
studies specialists were supposed to be
loyal Americans who learned about
foreign areas in US universities then
traveled to exotic places to carry out
research and returned to publish their
conclusions preferably in English this
model of area studies serve the national
interest of the United States in a more
or less unproblematic way by making the
peculiarities of foreign cultures
intelligible to the policymakers
responsible for managing them when
President Kennedy's National Security
Advisor McGeorge Bundy had difficulty
figuring out what Fidel Castro was up to
he famously called his successor as Dean
of the Faculty of Arts and Sciences at
Harvard to ask who's our man on Latin
America yes he was looking for a man
Harvard got into Latin American Studies
because the Dean could not find even one
for many years my own work has kept me
in close contact with discussions about
area studies and the questions to be
addressed this evening by Nick Dirk's I
joined professor professor both at
president Bollinger and the rest of you
in
anticipating this lecture by a colleague
I've had the pleasure of knowing and
admiring ever since I came to Columbia
in fact I think it was Nick who hired me
please welcome executive vice president
for arts and sciences Dean of the
Faculty of Arts and Sciences and Franz
Boas professor of anthropology and
history Nicholas B Dirk's
Thank You Lee thank you John thank you
all for coming this evening
I know it's presidents day and most of
my friends outside Columbia can't
believe that we aren't on holiday and so
I'm especially pleased to see all of you
here tonight and just by the way I have
been involved in hiring a number of
people at Columbia over the last eight
years nobody makes me happier to think
of as someone I was in part involved in
hiring than John cotesworth Mike
distinguished colleague so I begin my
lecture by invoking the honor not only
of giving the University lecture but of
holding a chair named after Franz Boas
one of Columbia's most distinguished
ancestors who as was without debate the
most important anthropologist in the
United States during his long career
most of which he spent at Columbia
founding the first American Department
of Anthropology in 1896 and training
some of America's most important
anthropologists before retiring after
spending 40 years chairing his
department I retired after only spending
six so believe me I have to respect that
many of his students went off to other
major universities to establish
department's of anthropology that
carried on his work and academic mission
including Alfred Kroeber of Berkeley and
Melville Hershkovitz at Northwestern
boas famously trained Zora Neale Hurston
Margaret Mead and Ruth Benedict and
collaborated directly with w e BD boys
in the establishment of the NA n double
acp he promoted a relativist concept of
culture and history to refute
evolutionary understandings that
naturalized racial inferiority and he
used every opportunity he could to apply
his general research to denounce the
kind of racism that he encountered
during his lifetime he was a domineering
academician who played a major role in
Columbia's early twentieth century
history building anthropology into a
powerhouse supporting the development of
East Asian Studies especially for their
role in the undergraduate curriculum
critiquing the insularity of academic
disciplinary
professionalism and quarreling with
Nicholas Marie Butler Colombia's
president during most of the years po
has taught here over academic freedom
now boas was also an active public
intellectual not only championing the
rights and civilizational claims of
african-americans but criticizing
American foreign policy especially in
connection with his dissent over
Wilson's decision to enter World War one
it was his opposition to the war that
led to his falling out with Butler as
also to his public attacks on a group of
Harvard anthropologists for
collaborating with the war in a way he
thought fundamentally compromised the
conduct of science in a letter to the
editor of the nation in 1919 Bo has not
only called Wilson a hypocrite an
American democracy a fiction he decried
what he called the prostitution of
science by anthropologists who had
worked as government spies in Mexico
during the war under cover of
anthropological fieldwork he noted that
and I quote we all know scientists who
in private life do not come up to the
standard of truthfulness but who
nevertheless would not consciously
falsify the results of their researches
the person however who uses science as a
cover for political spine who demeans
himself to pose before a foreign
government as an investigator and asked
for assistance and his alleged
researches in order to carry on under
this cloak his political machinations
prostitutes science in an unpardonable
way and forfeits the right to be classed
as a scientist the anthropologist whom
Boas railed against had been recruited
by the US Office of Naval Intelligence
in some of the first fledgling efforts
of espionage reported by the US
government working in Central America to
report on German u-boats and submarine
bases along the Gulf of Mexico Boaz's
attack led to his being censured by the
American Anthropological Association a
censure that was only lifted in 2003 as
also to the charge that he was
conducting vicious academic politics in
this case Columbia vs. Harvard by other
means but it did reveal whatever else
was going on his conviction that
anthropology had to
the highest scientific standards was on
the basis of scientific authority that
he made his claims about fundamental
issues concerning the nature and meaning
of race culture human biology
civilization and history for boas
academic truth and public discourse
required full transparency and scrutiny
he was therefore not without irony that
many of his closest students and
colleagues worked in intelligence and as
spies for the US war effort in world war
ii in what seemed at the time a time
when there was little dissent among
academics about the war a natural
extension of Boaz his fundamental belief
in the public coin of science indeed
Boaz was hardly against using
anthropology for public and indeed in
indeed political purposes as I've just
said and in some ways it was precisely
his influence that led some of his most
illustrious students perhaps most
conspicuously Margaret Mead and Ruth
Benedict to use anthropology for the war
effort during the Second World War but
the idea of formal espionage in the u.s.
ran up against the fact that at the dawn
of World War two the US was the only
great power without a formal and central
institution charged with the collection
and production of global intelligence
both the Army and the Navy had
intelligence units among them the ones
that the Harvard anthropologists spied
for but for the most part they were
staffed by military officers with no
particular expertise and intelligence or
for that matter in world affairs while
the FBI was limited in statute if not
always in practice to domestic
activities the economic crises of the
1930s had exacerbated isolationist
tendencies in the years before the war
tendencies that took on particular force
in various political movements conceived
to keep the u.s. out of World War two
Roosevelt however was not only under
growing pressure from Churchill to
provide logistical economic and soon
military support for Britain's war
effort he was aware early on of the need
for the u.s. to play a more active role
on the world stage to consolidate its
own power and prosperity as he
contemplated the likely entry of the
u.s. into the new
he became keenly aware of the need for a
new kind of brain trust organized to
provide strategic as well as military
intelligence in 1940 FDR who
increasingly anticipated the likely need
for direct American involvement called
on William J Donovan aka Wild Bill
Donovan he was called Wild Bill because
of his exploits on the football field as
a undergraduate for Columbia College
where he graduated in 1905 and later
graduated from the Columbia Law School
and he was called upon by FDR to conduct
a series of overseas missions as his
personal representative Donovan traveled
to England during the summer of 1940 to
assess Britain's capacity to resist a
possible German invasion consulted
extensively with British intelligence
officers and then spent several months
visiting the Balkans and other countries
in the Mediterranean Basin he returned
to Washington convinced that the u.s.
was in urgent need of strategic
information as well as of more general
political and psychological knowledge to
prepare for what he felt to be the
coming total war when he submitted his
memo to Roosevelt he recommended that
the president assemble a team of what he
called carefully selected trained minds
and on July 11 1941 Roosevelt created a
new civilian position called the
coordinator of information reporting
directly to him and asked Donovan to
serve in that role
Donovan commenced his work by
establishing what he called the research
and analysis branch convinced as he was
that the fundamental challenge was that
the u.s. lacked basic knowledge about
the world he developed a highly academic
notion of strategic intelligence
predicated in large part on his
admiration for the intelligence services
of the British Empire he was not wrong
either about the capabilities of
existing military intelligence or about
the virtually non-existent reservoir of
knowledge about the world available
outside those agencies in government and
elsewhere universities were especially
deficient in scholarly expertise about
the world outside Europe and North
America there were of course historians
of
Germany and Russia but contemporary
social science was barely developed and
a few scholars who worked on regions
outside the West were mostly
anthropologists working on tribal and
primitive societies or classicists and
archaeology's working archaeologists
working on ancient civilizations Donovan
decided to engage in a massive effort to
recruit leading academics to serve as
civilian researchers with the goal of
generating detailed empirical reports
that were then to be analyzed by the
board of analysts responsible for making
policy recommendations consulting with
Archie Archibald MacLeish who has
librarian of Congress himself convened
representatives of the Social Science
Research Council and the American
Council of learned societies to
recommend scholars appropriate for such
a project
Donovan called upon James Finney Baxter
the third president of Williams College
and a respected US diplomatic and
military historian William L Langer to
head the board Langer who had taught
diplomatic history at Harvard was
charged in effect to be the Dean of the
RNA branch and he set out to recruit the
best and the brightest often
irrespective of their particular
expertise necessary of course because
there were often no scholars having the
expertise that he was seeking almost all
the scholars who were called served
despite difficult conditions and
periodic misgivings most of these
scholars shared the belief that scholars
were obliged to come out of the ivory
tower and serve the national interest
compelled by the circumstances of the
war and their advocacy for American
intervention to make their training and
learning relevant but at least some of
these same scholars reflecting in part
the new commitment to an American
version of ronke and objectivism were
also deeply concerned not to allow
ideological fervor or the war itself to
influence either their research or their
analysis though of course they did
succumb to regimes of secrecy and
strategy nevertheless Pearl Harbor of
course not only put paid to American
reluctance to join the war it also led
Roosevelt to create the Office of
Strategic Services the OSS a much more
ambitious enterprise
that was to be established and directed
by none other than Donovan who took the
research and analysis branch directly
into his newly formed OSS in early 1942
a year into the experiment he decided to
scrap its fundamental organization the
functional subdivisions most of them
organized around disciplines and
reorganized the whole effort instead of
around disciplines to reflect what he
called the regional theaters of
operation rather than the academic
division of labor and I hate to say it
but there were some disciplines that
resisted this reorganization more than
others and the most independent of all
were economists they did succumb while
Bill Donovan made sure that with all due
respect the new regional and
interdisciplinary groups really in some
sense and I'm arguing this here tonight
the first regional and interdisciplinary
groups in the u.s. focused on Europe the
Soviet Union but soon also focused on
Asia and Latin America
Baxter recruited Sherman Kent an
historian of early 19th century France
from Yale for us to organize the
political group and then to establish
the European division Conyers read a
Nestorian of Tudor England was brought
in from the history department at Penn
to direct research on the British Empire
well it's a bit of a stretch but you
could see there's the continuity there
Gerald T Robinson an historian of Russia
with a PhD from Columbia was recruited
from Cornell to set up the USSR division
Ralph Bunche was recruited from Howard
University to deal with the subjects of
colonial policy and administration
native polyp native problems and race
relations within the British Empire a
cohort of historians some already
eminent and most on their way to become
so were brought to Washington 40
professional historians and all
including seven future presidents of the
American Historical Association why
whether they were presidents of the aah
a because they served in the a in the
OSS or because the USS was so good at
recruiting then we'll talk about that
later
while the Washington Kappas grew the OSS
also placed academics and overseas
missions to collect as well as to
analyze information London was the
largest of these OSS branch campuses but
there were missions in other parts of
Europe North America North Africa the
Middle East and Asia academics were
posted not just to these missions but as
agents to gather intelligence outside
the mission bases as well
the anthropologist Cora Dubois and
Gregory Bateson were installed as
undercover agents in candy Sri Lanka
where they coordinated the work of
agents across both India and Southeast
Asia
Joseph Spencer and John Kay Fairbank
were among some 50 China specialists who
were sent to bases in the wartime
capital at Chongqing and later and could
mean other analysts were moved into
newly liberated areas as soon as they
had been secured as for example in
Algiers and some OSS operatives
including Perry Miller Franz Newman John
Clive Karl Karl Kasem Karl cherski H
Stuart Hughes Felix Gilbert sorry dude
that list but my colleagues were
historians will know this is a very
distinguished group indeed and an
economist Karl Kaizen who went on to
direct the Institute for Advanced Study
Oh hasten to add were sent to Germany at
the end of the war to evaluate
conditions and adjudicate the future of
universities there as well now into the
OSS the research and analysis branch had
prepared reports on a wide range of
issues from the political views of
Schaal de Gaulle to the supply of oil on
the Eastern Front from the looting
damaging and possible removal of
valuable artworks in Germany to the
condition of food rations across Europe
regional specialists produced reports on
the history and status of the Communist
Party of India and on the puppet regime
in Nanking historians look back on the
way experiences in the First World War
might help predict possible outcomes in
the second while economists attempted to
measure the productive capacity and
economic resilience of Germany under
increasingly desperate wartime
conditions anthropologists famously
studied whether Japanese soldiers would
ever surrender or whether the
assassination of the Emperor would lead
to victory
while psychologists evaluated German
predilections to follow authority
figures and analyze German political
speeches for clues about military
operations now even if it was the case
as many in the Truman administration
argued that the OSS had extremely
limited influence on the outcome of the
war itself
these wartime efforts did have a
profound impact on the intellectual
landscape of post-war American
University life
muffled though it was by the lifetime
vow of secrecy OSS operatives took many
OSS scholars were profoundly affected by
their wartime experience not least
Herbert Marcuse Oh another OSS RN a
branch operative who worked throughout
the war in the OSS writing long tracks
delineating the fascist States
manipulation of crude populist politics
Ruth Benedict one of Boaz's most
accomplished students as I said before
wrote her classic study the
chrysanthemum and the sword based
largely on the study she did on Japanese
behavioural patterns for the Office of
War Information
the most significant legacy of the
research and analysis branch was
significantly not in European studies
despite the important role of European s
both in in RNA in Washington and of
course increasingly in Europe itself in
the closing years in the closing days of
the war but in the postwar development
of area studies McGeorge Bundy who
already has been mentioned by by John
who of course used to know how important
the Dean of the Faculty of Arts and
Sciences in Harvard was he was the Dean
at Harvard in the early 50s and after
that had a succession of lesser jobs
working for the Kennedy administration
and then heading the Ford Foundation but
he wrote when he was heading the Ford
Foundation in 1964 that and I quote the
first great center of area studies in
the United States was not located in any
university but in Washington in the
Office of Strategic Services in very
large measure the area study programs
developed in American universities in
the years after the war were manned
and they were for the most part Manton
yet there are these exceptions and I'll
talk about some more in a second
directed who are stimulated by graduates
of the OSS a remarkable institution half
cops-and-robbers
and half faculty meeting now from my
experience I have to say I'm not sure
which is which but I think the Ford
Foundation had been one of the great
funders of area studies along with
Carnegie and Rockefeller and Bundy was
well aware of the direct line from the
OSS to the post-war emergence of area
studies in major US universities Philip
Moseley longtime professor of Russian
Studies at Columbia wrote that during
the time of the RNA and I quote the
field of inquiry was if anything wider
ranging more recalcitrant and more
poignant in its meaning for human lives
than even the broadest academic program
of today the RNA experience showed that
an analyst of many different skills not
only could but must work in harness to
accomplish many types of research thus
the determination to establish graduate
programs have been a disciplinary
teaching and research on Russia and the
USSR grew out of both pre-war hopes and
wartime urgencies and of quote
Robin winks and historian of empire for
many years at Yale who wrote a classic
study of the OSS entitled cloak and gown
said much the same thing when he wrote
quote it is no exaggeration to say that
the rapid growth of various studies
programs at the graduate level in which
several disciplines together with the
necessary languages focus their methods
jointly and in genuine cooperation on a
given area grew out of the structure of
the Foreign Service the OSS and the work
of ancillary groups indeed OSS alumni
were to be found in virtually all major
area studies programs often becoming the
founders of new programs in the post-war
years
Gerald Robinson went on from his role as
head of the RNA Russia desk to move from
Cornell to Columbia as professor of
history where he became the first head
of the Russian Institute here at
Columbia before passing it on to Philip
Mosely John K Fairbanks
course returned to Harvard from his time
in China with the OSS to set up the
largest post-war program in East Asian
Studies but perhaps the figure from the
OSS who had the single greatest
influence on the development of a
particular regional study in the OSS was
W Norman Brown professor of Sanskrit at
the University of Pennsylvania and
founder both of the first South Asia
regional Studies program and the
American Institute of Indian studies
Brown had grown up in India as the son
of a missionary who went on to earn a
PhD in Sanskrit studies from Johns
Hopkins he was recruited to Penn in 1929
as the only India specialist at Penn he
actually replaced Franklin Edgerton a
sanskrit as who then went to yale but
that was it one Sanskrit is all of India
despite his scholarly work on early
Indian texts he did in fact develop an
interest in contemporary Indian spoke
Hindi as a result of his missionary
upbringing that was more than enough for
his colleague Conyers read the Twitter
historian who headed the the the British
Empire Deskin in the RNA branch to
recruit him to head the first india desk
so when Brown whoop moved to Washington
in mid 1942 he recruited a missle milf
miscellaneous group of students and
young academics to work with him on the
india desk and he worked closely with
ralph bunche also in the british empire
section and dean rusk who worked in the
pentagon browne presided over his
interdisciplinary team of scholars
overseeing the preparation of a number
of manuscripts that whether written by
him or not all bore his influence the
papers document a growing American
critique of British imperial rule in
South Asia and developing consensus
about the importance of supporting the
Indian nationalist movement especially
the goal of Gandhi to lead India to
political independence without either a
violent struggle against the British or
the setting of caste or class interests
against each other Gandhi's noble vision
and his embrace of non-violence appeal
to Brown even as US academics and policy
makers were largely unsympathetic to
British Empire at large and Churchill's
imperialist jingoism
particular the u.s. also saw the Empire
and Churchill's adamant refusal to give
nationalist sentiment any quarter as a
great potential threat to the war effort
against Japan the major mission of the
India desk in Washington and
increasingly of us operatives in India
was to monitor the extent and character
of Indian disaffection with British rule
and to evaluate whether this
disaffection would lead either to non
cooperation with the Allied effort or
even worse active collaboration with
Japan which of course had recruited
prisoners of war after the fall of
Singapore from the Indian Army to
penetrate to try to penetrate the
eastern border of India across Burma
FDR himself had been on record for some
years for his general disapproval of
British colonial rule in India and some
of his sharpest exchanges with Churchill
concerned the Empire while Churchill
famously declared that the Empire would
not end on his watch Roosevelt became
increasingly disturbed by the failure of
the British to engage Indian leaders and
serious negotiations about self-rule now
Roosevelt never pushed the diplomatic
disagreement to the breaking point he
deferred instead to wartime exigencies
and strength and Churchill's strenuous
insistence on American neutrality visa V
India but it is striking how different
the developing view of u.s. political
leaders and scholars was from the
prevailing view among the British who
saw their Empire as absolutely critical
to their post-war not to mention their
wartime survival both both during the
war and afterwards FDR's to wartime
emissaries to New Delhi Louis Johnson
and William Phillips had been welcomed
initially by the British because of
their Pro Empire views but soon after
just spending short periods of time in
India they became both of them deeply
supportive of Indian nationalism and
they became genuinely fearful of
possible support for the Japanese
invasion across the Burma border in the
end they both genuinely embraced the
cause of self-determination in India and
were very much supporters of both Gandhi
and Nehru now both Johnson and Philips
were sent back to the US after falling
afoul of the British Philips was the
source of a major diplomatic crisis when
his report to FDR containing serious
criticisms of the British policy of
divide and roll was leaked to the press
and emerged Andrew Pearson's column in
the Washington star in 1944 now Phillips
who had been the head of the OSS office
in Great Britain before being sent to
India had in fact established an office
in Delhi that engaged in far more active
intelligence activities than merely
using British compilations of political
information he initiated clandestine
information gathering through a network
of Americans installed in various posts
in India and in salon ostensibly of
course on other missions though I think
not in the category that upset Boaz so
much working as academics explicitly
David Mandelbaum an anthropologist who
had done fieldwork in India before the
war and set up the South Asia program at
Berkeley after the war collected
intelligence for the OSS in India and
kora Dubois who I mentioned before was
shifted from India to salon where Abele
assisted by Julia Child whose first
recipe by the way was for a shark
repellent to put on mines in Japanese
waters it worked but of course it worked
she coordinated information about the
spread of Japanese influence across
Southeast Asia dubois an anthropologist
who had initially done her work in
Southeast Asia before turning to South
Asia went on to become the first tenured
woman in Harvard's Department of
Anthropology after the war and indeed
almost all the influential names
associated with the development of South
Asian regional studies in the u.s. came
to their academic relationship with
India directly out of the war many of
them out of the OSS in 1944 w Norman
Brown advocated the serious development
and funding of Oriental Studies in a
draft document in which he wrote and I
quote during the course of the war the
US government agencies have needed
information about the orient to a degree
far beyond anticipation our nation must
never again be caught so ill equipped
with knowledge and specialists on the
Orient as it was at the end of
18:41 remember that because it obviously
I was not the case he also noted giving
voice to another area of growing US
interest however I just mentioned this
because obviously the u.s. developing US
interest in India is more complicated
than just supporting Indian nationalism
the post-war orient will also possibly
be freer than before to engage in trade
with the Occident to meet this new
situation America will need to acquire
information and develop personnel able
to handle the increased political
business and cultural relationships in
1947 he revised this draft and he
expanded his vision of Oriental Studies
and a document that led directly to the
creation of the first Department of
Oriental Studies the first I'm sorry the
first Department of South Asian regional
studies at the University of
Pennsylvania securing major funding from
Carnegie Rockefeller and Ford to do so
he recruited all of the scholars who had
worked with him during the war in
Washington for the RNA branch by the
academic year 1949-50
a complete program for South Asian
regional studies had been established
under his leadership with an affiliated
faculty of 21 scholars covering all
sorts of fields and it in turn trained
almost all of the first generation of
u.s. South Asian us and provided a model
for in a set of institutional
intellectual concerns critical to the
development of South Asian Studies
across the United States for many years
thereafter South Asian area studies thus
was born almost fully formed in the
immediate post-war week years reflecting
both some of the work that had been
associated with the strategic concerns
of the OSS and the peculiar intellectual
orientation and perspective of this
particular scholar his missionary roots
his sanskritic
scholarship and his sense that Indian
nationalism would be fully compatible
with the role he envisioned for the u.s.
in the post-war period he was also a
textbook Orientalist as he wrote in his
major book published in 1954 a book
entitled the United States in India in
Pakistan it was in the same series as
the books written by Reischauer and
Fairbank the United States and China the
United States and Japan the first books
in many ways written for a broad
American Audie
it's about Asia he wrote there the
greatest achievements of characteristic
Indian civilization are in religion and
philosophy but his intentions were
framed within his larger goals to
increase understanding and exchange
between India and Pakistan and the
United States and his political
sensibility was not just anti colonial
but liberal though he believed the
change would come slow to a civilization
that had remained fundamentally the same
across 5000 years but this is the
historical background that provided the
context for my own academic
socialization into South Asian area
studies from the India Office of the
Fulbright Program which actually funded
my father to go to India to teach at a
South Indian college when I was 12 years
old
thus beginning my own interest in and
relationship to India to the creation
and funding of area studies at
universities such as Chicago where I did
my graduate PhD work while uniting the
humanities and the social sciences in a
partnership that carried on William
langars vision of useful knowledge area
Studies was itself committed to a new
kind of relationship sorry between the
United States and the developing world
assured that American global interests
had little in common with those of
previous European empires that
modernization was an inexorable process
that would lead to political and
economic development along with mutual
understanding shared interests and of
course commercial exchange with the US
and that US universities had to provide
training and regional languages cultures
politics and histories to create a new
cadre of intellectuals and academics
prepared to guide us attitudes towards a
new world order these convictions were
soon both enhanced and of course colored
by the growing sense of a world struggle
with the Soviet Union as the Cold War
became a central justification for area
studies even as many academics many area
studies academics including many former
OSS operatives found themselves turned
on by McCarthy hue AK and an
aggressively partisan CIA and FBI area
studies became further polarized and
politicized by the growing opposition to
the war in Vietnam in the 1960s and
later in the pollutant
the political and epistemological
critiques of the 70s and 80s but the
final critique of area studies was
enabled perhaps even caused by the
geopolitical transformations that began
with the fall of the wall and the demise
of course of the Soviet Union various
studies continued in US universities
after 1989 but they lost considerable
prestige they became increasingly
directed by scholars in the humanities
rather than the social sciences and
since then the social sciences have this
is a broad generalization but
nevertheless the social sciences have
largely rejected the preoccupations of
various studies isn't sufficiently
rigorous comparative and relevant to the
new phenomena labeled under the term
globalization
well 9/11 rekindled the same kinds of
concerns expressed by Brown about how
ill-prepared the US was in 1941
propelling at least for a time funding
support for Arabic language and regional
study the tide of globalization was too
strong to turn back ironically much of
the support for area studies over the
past two decades has come from immigrant
and international communities that have
understood the importance of supporting
curricular and scholarly commitments to
specific regions and nations to
celebrate their achievements and
normalize their position in u.s. society
not from the foundation world not from
the kinds of interests that propelled
area studies before and yet while there
was widespread consensus about the
nature of area studies even after the
political crises associated with the war
in Vietnam there is surprisingly little
consensus even today about what global
studies should be we all acknowledge the
need to understand the structure and
function of global economic markets
financial systems and over the phret
past few months in particular sovereign
entailments in both even as there is
relatively shared agreement about the
need to understand the resilience of
cultural religious and social
differences in the globalizing world
there is growing concern to chart out
new institutional mechanisms for global
governance given challenges ranging from
climate control to international law
global inequality and the need to
regulate global markets and financial
institutions
given the scale of these changes and the
extent to which they simply do not map
on to any available constitutional and
theoretical model for sovereignty the
lack of consensus seems inevitable and
for the moment at least perhaps more
natural than the consensus that
developed out of the state of emergency
represented by the Second World War but
it is still surprising how little
progress we have made in working towards
a sense of common purpose as we chart
out the response of the American
University to the global challenges and
opportunities of our day and by this I
don't mean here the establishment of
branch campuses or the heightened
concerns about student and faculty
market shares in a newly globalized
academic world in the few minutes that
remain of my lecture this evening I'm
going to try to highlight just at least
the contours of what I think we should
be debating in relation to these
important issues first it is necessary
to remember that area studies have much
to teach us now as they did then the
belated recognition that American
universities had little in the way of
expertise in the histories cultures
literature's languages societies and
politics of discrete world regions might
have been the inevitable consequence of
a newly dominant nation entering a world
war and assuming a new set of global
geopolitical and economic interests but
it had an extraordinarily salutary
effect on our academic institutions well
beyond any of those interests whole new
worlds of academic inquiry opened up
creating new programs centers institutes
and departments while expanding the
horizons of all civilizational
historical political literary and social
study perhaps most important of all the
teaching of languages from Indonesian to
Wolof from Vietnamese to Tamil was
supported on a massive scale for the
first time the rapidly expanding scale
of the American University in the
postwar years allowed for innovation
through accretion rather than conflicts
over scarce resources those were the
days while our knowledge base genuinely
expanded without culture wars at least
for a time anthropology and geography
had initiated the study of the wider
world but for the first time core
departments of history political
science economics and sociology included
world specialists even as new humanistic
fields were added through departments of
regional languages and literatures while
area studies remained institutionally
sequestered to some extent they leaked
out of their containers in all sorts of
ways notably spawning schools of
international affairs and creating new
departments of regional language
literature and culture though notably
concentrating more on graduate than on
undergraduate education at the same time
there was a growing sense that area
studies had sacrificed disciplinary
rigor and comparative reach as the
Social Sciences became more committed to
theory and methodology they began to
marginalize area specialists or at least
to hire them for more than and sometimes
even despite their local knowledge
throughout these years the
anthropologist Clifford Geertz argued
eloquently for the importance of local
knowledge and he did so in such
theoretically eloquent terms that he was
effective in addressing humanists and
social scientists alike he had reminded
us that village fieldwork the
ethnographic and premature of
anthropology in places like India in the
decades after the war was not so much
the study of villages as it was the
study in villages and when he did so he
made it clear to a broad audience that
the view from the village was different
not just from the Metropole but from
other villages were towns or cities or
regions as well in one of his classic
works islam observed he famously noted
that muslims and morocco and indonesia
both bowed towards the same place when
they prayed but they did so from
opposite directions
garrets had global interests to be sure
whatever he was studying but he was the
first to say that his theoretical
understanding of thinkers as various as
Weber and Durkheim where Dewey and
Saussure was fundamentally changed by
having read them through his experiences
of ethnographic particularity in the
face of liberalisation and globalization
however area studies hardly seemed
suited to the task at hand understanding
global flows and
Goods and markets desires and pleasures
ideas and movements information and
media the unprecedented connectivity and
pace of the world in which we live as
borders and the Iron Curtain broke down
markets opened up air travel increased
the internet exploded and global
commerce not just expanded but
flourished in a way no one ever would
have thought possible especially in
places like China and India
globalization required different
disciplinary theoretical methodological
and conceptual frameworks to grasp what
was seen not just as new but as
radically transforming the relationship
of discrete places to a world without
place but I would revert nevertheless to
one of Gerrits is classic formulations
to caution us from imagining that new
social theories should mimic these de
territory territory alized abstractions
at the level of their greatest
generality as Garrett's noted I quote
what we need it seems are not enormous
ideas nor the abandonment of
synthesizing notions altogether what we
need are ways of thinking that are
responsive to particularity to
individuality zaw oddities
discontinuities contrasts and
singularities responsive to what Charles
Taylor has called deep diversity a
plurality of ways of belonging and being
and that yet can draw from them from it
a sense of connectedness a connectedness
that is neither comprehensive nor
uniform primal nor changeless but
nonetheless real in short we must study
not just the connectedness of things but
the things that connect what happens
when they connect and what connection
looks like from the specific places and
embodied subjects that inhabit the deep
diversity of the social cultural
cultural political intellectual literary
and economic world that we still live in
second in reviewing the history of area
studies it is clear that institutional
change of the sort that took place after
World War two was the result of the
recognition of real strategic knowledge
in real strategic need for new kinds of
knowledge
as we reflect on our institutional
responses to the new global order it is
tempting to make arguments for change
based solely on the same logic of
relevance and responsiveness and to
invoke a similar sense of urgency we
have often noted how inappropriate it is
to continue to confront the world of the
21st century using a disciplinary menu
that has survived virtually intact from
the moment of its origins in the late
19th century when the world was a very
different place indeed
area studies constituted one of the most
dramatic changes of the 20th century at
least for the university and as we have
just seen they emerged from a war effort
that perforce valued political utility
over general knowledge but in the rush
to area studies it might be argued at
least in retrospect that they became too
sequestered in graduate institutes and
separate language departments to
genuinely infuse most of the core
disciplines and much of our basic
education we know from the basic
sciences that the goals of applied
science are often best met by research
in areas that initially have little in
the way of utility to recommend them now
without a world war or even a cold war
we have the luxury to move to the global
and a more deliberative engaged
disciplined and intellectually serious
way than was the case with the rise of
area studies perhaps both the
disciplines and global studies will
reachable change in beneficial ways as a
result provided we do not abandon our
sense of urgency altogether and although
I don't have the time nor you the
patience to allow me to explain more
about what I mean here I would add that
I believe that the core disciplines in
both the humanities and the social
sciences need to take onto global in
extremely serious ways even as their
fundamental methods the philosophical
theological or Chi vil interpretive
anesthetic on the one side and the
historical sociological quantitative and
nomothetic on the other need to be both
broadened and transformed as a
consequence this has implications for
the way we think about basic issues
around values the meaning of the human
the hermeneutic imagination the
identification and evaluation of data
and research and the character of
comparative and theoretical analysis
itself
third and not unrelated to my previous
point we need to maintain a balance
between the public and the scholarly
Boaz was prescient and courageous in his
embrace of the public and implications
of his newly developed anthropological
theories of culture his outreach to D
boys and the n-double-a-cp as well as
his outspoken address of other public
issues ranging from the war to third
world anti colonial nationalist
movements marks him in my view as a
model for the public intellectual who
moved comfortably from between the field
the lab and the classroom on the one
side and the public domain on the other
always aware of the differences between
his academic and teaching
responsibilities on campus and his
social and political commitments in the
world
he used his prestige as a leading social
scientist to advance public causes but
in both kept an unwavering commitment to
academic rigor and transparency
nevertheless and leaving aside the range
of academic and political differences
over globalization in the u.s. this last
balancing act is all the more difficult
today because it is perforce part of the
global domain itself this domain
encompasses unprecedented levels of
disagreement about fundamental questions
from ideas and constitutional provisions
about academic and political freedom to
basic understandings about virtually
every global issue whether cultural
political social intellectual
environmental or economic not only are
there radically different contexts for
say freedom of speech the press or
academic work there are extravagantly
different ways of reading almost every
global issue examples abound from the
recent controversy regarding the Center
for global governance at the London
School of Economics to the swirl of
questions around freedom of speech in
China or the Gulf two debates over
censorship in India and Europe to the
wide range of views over the costs and
benefits of the new global financial
system global studies if they are
genuinely to be global cannot be done
without situating them intellectually as
well as institutionally biologically as
well as practically in specific global
contexts
and however open-ended circuitous
unconventionally Network contingently
bounded and even ad hoc and
serendipitous these contexts and
connections this entails a corollary
balance between the global and the
regional to return to the first point I
made this is not though to argue for a
return to area studies as they were
unmediated either by legitimate
critiques of the area studies paradigm
where the newly scaled perspectives
flowing out of a global cast of mind it
is instead to argue for something that I
would call worldly knowledge both to get
around the limitations of the terms
global local area regional and so on and
to avoid some of the pitfalls and
debates over similar kinds of terms that
have been used for some of the same
purposes I'm using worldly here such as
cosmopolitanism the global is here not
just is is not just here to stay it has
raised issues that are no longer
avoidable not least among not least
among them the realization that area
studies can never again be the study of
them by us whatever that means
indeed we must all engage the protocols
of knowledge making and teaching in a
global setting because precisely the
internal and external boundaries of an
older area studies model have been
redrawn and fundamentally reconstituted
for us sitting here at the heart of this
America this major American University
this means asking not just about the
nature of the global university but the
global implications of our most
distinctive identities and commitments
not just about where we are from but how
we negotiate questions ranging from
academic freedom to basic research from
the role of Technology and education to
the fundamental nature of the university
in the global future the question
however with which I'm going to conclude
my remarks this evening and I will
conclude soon I promise
concerns the liberal arts because of
their especially critical role in the
educational mission underlying the
entire structure of the university now
there are of course many ways of
thinking about the liberal arts from
ideas of general education of the sort
we enshrine in the core curriculum here
at Columbia to a broad notion of the
need for students to take a wide range
of elective or distributional courses
well outside of their specialization or
major
whatever our institutional traditions
and definitions the liberal arts is a
distinctively American idea
genealogically connected to classical
and even theological education morally
animated by commitments to the study of
fundamental human debates dilemmas and
discourses institutionally propelled by
the educational belief in training
students in critical thinking reading
and writing and politically justified by
the argument that education is about the
production and reproduction of an
enlightened democratic citizenry the
mission of the liberal arts is what
gives us the luxury to think that higher
education is not just vocational
training for specified careers
it is however and we all know this under
severe threat in the American Academy
today damage first by some of the
fallout of the cannon and culture wars
but hurt far more grievously I think by
the more general loss of consensus about
what it means to emphasize values can
secular values which is to say views
about the meaning of life not
specifically sanctioned by religious
precept or practice consecutive values
make an enduring claim on broad
constituencies for whom the only real
value behind the liberal arts may be
their general institutional prestige
rather than their substantive nature
neither is there consensus about the
claim that our role is to produce an
enlightened citizenry since this of
course has occasioned growing concerns
that we're producing precisely the wrong
kind of citizenry perhaps most
debilitating of all there is a sense
that the liberal arts do not produce
skills that either advance the general
well-being of our societies nations and
economies nor guarantee employment
upsetting the entire calculus that a
college education makes for a better
material as well as moral life
especially given its huge and seemingly
disproportionate cost now the liberal
arts are still fundamental to the
American University thank God but we
have only to look around us to see the
danger they are in it is within a
context of steady erosion of support for
for that matter of the genuine belief
that the liberal arts is what makes the
American college and university not just
distinctive but exemplary
that I've been thinking about what it
might mean to globalize the liberal arts
themselves wondering what it will take
to ensure that the liberal arts survive
in this age of globalism at the same
time that they become as perforce they
must genuinely global the liberal arts
do not mean a great deal in China or
India or the Gulf states and at the
level of undergraduate education don't
figure significantly in European
interests in American Americanizing
their universities either were fund
raising tuition charging global market
shares for students and the like are
much more salient even if there would be
an interest in taking the liberal arts
along with the rest it is not clear how
their value can be described in
universal terms with anything like a
compelling narrative writing still
matters whether in business engineering
or for that matter the Internet but
critical thinking what lessons might we
draw from the fact that some of the most
successful and brilliance of our spies I
had to get back to spies learn the
attitudes and techniques of counter
espionage from studying with the new
critics as English majors at Yale all
quips aside however we need to find I
think up ways better ways to argue not
just for the preservation of the liberal
arts at home but for the fundamentality
of the liberal arts for educational
values and aspirations everywhere no
matter what the local cultural political
or economic realities and irrespective
of the understandable global
predisposition to focus on vocation
technical training scientific
advancement and other absolutely and
unarguably critical needs the success of
the great American research university
has been in large part predicated on the
role that the liberal arts have played
in generating the spirit of creativity
innovation and basic research as
Jonathan Cole has recently forcefully
reminded us but they are even more
fundamental than that and there are
dangers and instrumentalizing the values
of critical thinking or the liberal arts
for fear we will lose sight of their
value for life itself this is not to
return us to the older registers of
meaning that confuse or conflate the
secular with the sacred or the intended
self of our quest for self-knowledge
with a reference untouched by the
changes in our technological economic
political cultural and social worlds
Paul Recor
broadened philosophical humanism with an
anthropological twist when he wrote that
the route to understanding the self is
through the detour of the other but the
point now is to recognize the essential
other nests at the notional self that
humanism began rather than ended with
the constitution of distinctions between
selves and others and the need for
humanist education to recognize that the
extent to which the self is
fundamentally global - thus the texts
histories canons genealogies debates
conundrums expressions and context of
humanistic inquiry and contemplation are
also global at every level and in every
language this is emphatically not to
rekindle the culture wars nor suggests
to return to identity politics it is
rather to insist on a radically new way
of identifying the core values and aims
of humanist education - think of the
humanistic self as genuinely plural to
construct genealogies for the inquiry
into selfhood that acknowledge the
canonic character of fundamental debates
while broadening the world of reference
influence and consequence to a genuinely
global stage but it is up to us to keep
that debate going and to ensure that we
have the tools to make this debate seem
as necessary and indeed as urgent as
possible while sacrificing none of its
complexity ambiguity or for that matter
utopianism one way or the other we
should be able to learn from the time
when many of our scholars were spies
without having to become spies all over
again
thank you very much
our speaker has agreed to answer
questions and I have agreed to make sure
that they're intellectually rigorous and
worth responding
censorship at home yes here hi
so in the context of our state your name
first and then Oh
my name is cooling and I'm a first year
at at the college so my question is I'm
taking the core right now and in terms
of our need for a truly global
university we have to say about the text
we read in literature humanities in
contemptible ization and music
humanities are they do they fit within
this picture of the global university or
is it to focus on just purely Western
values and history and texts thank you
for that question I was hoping that I
would get it from a student that's
important you know I'm teaching
contemporary civilization right now so
I'm very much in the midst of thinking
through some of the issues around our
core you're a freshman so look for my
section next year and we'll continue
this conversation but a couple of things
I'll say first that while it is
manifestly the case that contemporary
civilization for example is entitled
contemporary civilization in the West it
was from its origins of course that
responded to and engaged in very
important ways global issues my father
taught contemporary civilization when he
was a graduate student of philosophy in
the late 1940s and the source book that
he used for the course - I didn't
forty-seven the course book ends with
the last section being the charter of
the United Nations and addresses at the
end of contemporary civilization some of
the issues that have to do with the
post-war global challenge as it were for
the United States and in my own cc class
if I can reveal my syllabus to this
August group my students are reading
Burk on the French Revolution and on the
impeachment trial of Warren Hastings
having
do with the excesses of British
imperialism imperialism in the 18th
century and India so I think in fact
what the core can do is is do what it's
always done engage contemporary issues
and contexts through the kind of seminar
format and the kind of primary text
encounters that are so important to it
that being said we are working very hard
to secure more support for the global
core to ensure that the global core
becomes as important to as fundamental
to the core curriculum at Columbia as
let home cc music home and our home and
that's a continuous challenge but it is
something now that we can think about
doing because we have expanded the
faculty significantly in areas of global
aerial expertise and we have many many
faculty in fact working right now and
the Committee on the global core
thinking through new kinds of ways to
enhance our curriculum so thank you for
your question thanks Christian my name
is Roger incus and I was a student of
gyroid Robinson and Phillip Mosley at
the Russian Institute in 1953 and 1954
by the way I would recommend David
Angermann is a book called know thy
enemy it relates very much to what
you've been saying my question is I the
government in a study some years ago I
believe evaluating the relative
effectiveness and usefulness of various
professional groups to which it would
turn for information regarding areas and
there was the State Department analysts
the academic establishment and
journalists and they seem to have
concluded that the State Department
analysts turned out to be most effective
I wonder what your view is and a minor
yes
a minor footnote where were the
anthropologists when Roosevelt entered
the Japanese well some of them are
studying these
actually that's where we've Benedick got
her information I'm sure you know that
you know the this question of strategic
knowledge of strategically useful
knowledge is something that obviously
I'm trying to point to as a real problem
I in the history of this kind of area
studies
on the one hand and of course I'm trying
to argue for a certain kind of balance
between understanding the need to engage
not just real world issues but real
world issues from perspectives that
include the perspective of the United
States with a recognition that that
questions in China and India and Africa
need to be studied as much on their own
terms and for themselves as the
traditional canons and texts of Western
civilization or curricula right I mean
so that's another way of putting the
argument but you know we all know that
that some of the greatest humanists and
social scientists even when they worked
for their RNA branch produce stuff that
most of the military establishment
thought was complete garbage I mean I
can assure you that mark who says doc
mark uses proposals were not read very
widely outside of the R&A branch
particularly by his colleague ha Joe
Holborn who worked at the desk next to
to mark ooza and then went on of course
to be the great German historian at Yale
for many many years and whose daughter
Holborn great what's President the
University of she could but anyway
another just an aside if I may
since there was a book that just came
out this fall on the role of classicists
in the OSS it's an incredibly
interesting text and it reveals among
other things that the principal
professor of classics here at Columbia
for many years Moses hadass headed the
the Greek desk
at the in Cairo for the OSS during three
years of of the war as well so what I'm
saying here reverberates through much
more than just classical area studies
but anyway the point is that who defines
what is useful strategic knowledge is
all is often going to define a kind of
knowledge that is fundamentally at odds
with the things that we do in
universities even as there is a
recognition of the importance of what we
do and I think we have to engage
this-this-this as it were as a central
question for ourselves how to preserve
what is most important about not only
the university itself but how we conduct
ourselves and make our arguments and our
pitches for support within the
university and how we in fact engage
with the kinds of questions that we
should not ignore and that indeed I'm
happy to say Columbia we do not ignore a
final question before the reception yeah
my name is Dave Craig I'm from Columbia
Magazine and I wanted to ask what types
of debates or discussions might be
taking place today among our faculty
among our administrators given that our
presence around the world is in some
ways much more public and aboveboard
formalized such as with our global
centers sometimes in places that are
very interesting parts of the world
Turkey and China
Jordan places that might be liberalizing
and places in which we could imagine
that our presence simply our presence
could be used seen or perceived as a as
a political as having political
repercussions that might be out of our
control
on one hand we can imagine a professor
of Social Work going to a place and
providing political cover for people in
a country to do things that we as
Western liberals might consider good
things it also might open up the
possibility that a leader with
autocratic tendencies could ingratiate
themselves with Columbia's presence a
bit out of our control maybe less so
than
during World War two I wondered what
types of discussions are going on about
that well we're actually talking about
this all the time all right these some
of that some of the most central
questions that confront us as a
university that's a step that is
establishing not just global sensors but
new forms of relationships with
different parts of the world in a way
the the old model of area studies was a
model that allowed individual scholars
to establish very much on their own
their relationships with institutions
and scholars and governments and other
parts of the world and didn't in any way
hold the institution accountable in the
same kind of way that setting up a
center or branch campus or a set of very
public collaborations might and as we do
that you know we are always aware that
there are people looking at what we're
doing the president he can speak for
himself he's here but he was told at one
point when he was visiting the global
center in Beijing that the government
was extremely unhappy about the
importance of Tibet and Tibet studies at
Columbia and that threatened in fact to
overtake some of the things that we were
trying to do in Beijing there questions
about freedom of speech that that occur
in many of the of the public global
events that we sponsor and there are
issues of course constantly that that we
and others are having to wrestle with
having to do with you know how we
maintain our commitments to academic
freedom at the same time that we are
often in places where not only those
commitments are not shared but where
individual scholars who engage with us
and are invited to participate in public
events of one kind or another might in
fact find themselves at risk
for doing so no one way to respond to
this is to say you know it's too messy
out there we're just going to pull back
we don't want to sully ourselves and
we're going to effectively keep
ourselves pure by staying at home I
think that would be the wrong way to
engage this at the same time that there
are lines that need to be drawn and
and times when certain kinds of issues
have to in some sense be more directly
engaged than simply doing the kind of
negotiation on the side but in any case
I mean without going on any longer we
talk about that as faculty and
administrators all the time and it's one
of the most interesting challenges of
globalization it's certainly what I was
referring to in the text when I said
that the balance between the scholarly
and the public has now become
exponentially more complicated but also
of course more interesting Nick thank
you very much for stimulating and
brilliantly
you